Wisst ihr, was das hier ist?
Das sind amerikanische Globoli.
Warum zeige ich euch die?
Weil die hier besser sind
als deutsche Globoli.
Aber eins nach dem anderen: ich war
ja in den letzten Wochen in den USA.
Und dabei ist mir etwas ziemlich
interessantes aufgefallen:
Wie ihr vielleicht wisst,
gibt es in den USA keine Apotheken,
wie in Deutschland.
Sondern Pharmacies, das sind
Drogeriemarkt und Apotheke in einem.
Also da, wo man sich
dann Shampoo kauft,
holt man sich auch
seine Herzmedikamente.
Es gibt eine Theke für
rezeptpflichtige Medikamente.
Aber alle nicht-
rezeptpflichtige Medikamente,
für die man in Deutschland
trotzdem Apotheke muss,
z.B. Schmerzmittel oder
Sachen gegen Erkältung, usw.,
Die stehen einfach, wie Shampoo,
im Regal,
man kann sich einfach bedienen.
So, jetzt kommt das Spannende:
Ich dachte, ich schau
einfach mal so aus Neugier
nach homöopathischen Mitteln.
Ganz vereinzelt habe ich im Regal
zwischen den normalen Medikamenten
auch homöopathische Mittel entdeckt.
Zum Beispiel:
Aber es gab jetzt keine
Extraabteilungen in den Pharmacies.
Und auch keine Globoli, z.B.
Erst in dieser alternativen Pharmacy
wurde ich endlich fündig.
Und dann später auch noch
in einem alternativen Supermarkt.
Aber das eigentlich interessante ist,
was auf diesen homöopathischen
Mitteln draufsteht.
Also für die Wirksamkeit
gibt es keine akzeptierten
medizinischen Belege.
"Not FDA evaluated" heißt,
die offizielle Behörde,
die "Food and Drug Administration",
hat dieses Mittel nicht geprüft.
Und das ist nun mal so
bei Homöopathie,
es gibt eben für
homöopathische Mittel
tatsächlich keine
akzeptierte medizinische Belege.
Deswegen ist es
erst mal nicht verwunderlich,
dass der Disclaimer
hier draufstehen muss.
Aber bei uns in Deutschland
ist das ganz anders.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja
das hier mitbekommen:
"Globoli-Anbieter Hevert -
Pharmafirma geht juristisch
gegen Homöopathie-Kritiker vor".
Wie bitte?
Da geht es u.a. um diese Aussage:
Das ist ein homöopathisches Mittel.
Und bei homöopathischen Mitteln
fehlen bisher grundsätzlich
bei allen Mitteln,
die homöopathisch daherkommen,
ein Wirksamkeitsnachweis.
Dieser Wissenschaftler bekam von der
deutschen Homöopathie Firma Hevert
eine Abmahnung für diese Aussage.
Denn diese Aussage sei falsch.
Und wenn er sie wiederhole,
solle er dafür jedes Mal
eine hohe Geldstrafe zahlen.
Dieselbe Firma produziert aber auch
für den amerikanischen Markt.
Und da steht wiederum der uns
inzwischen bekannte Disclaimer drauf.
Wie bitte?
Wie kann es sein,
dass eine Firma in Deutschland
eine Abmahnung verteilen darf
für eine Aussage, die sie in den USA
auf ihre Verpackung schreiben müssen.
Die Antwort lautet:
Und hinter diesem
langweilig klingenden Wort
steckt eine unglaubliche Geschichte.
Deswegen, Freunde der Sonne,
setzt euch.
Macht es euch gemütlich,
holt einen Tee,
wir steigen jetzt ein in die Welt
des deutschen Arzneimittelgesetzes.
Und ihr werdet nicht glauben,
wie verrückt es gleich wird.
* Titelmusik *
Es gab eine Zeit, da war es
in Deutschland relativ einfach,
ein neues Medikament
auf den Markt zu bringen.
Der Hersteller musste das dafür
nur bei dem damaligen
Bundes-Gesundheitsamt registrieren.
Klingt vielleicht offiziell,
aber so eine Registrierung
erfordert keinen Nachweis
über die Wirkung oder Nebenwirkungen,
ob, oder wie es wirkt,
oder ob vielleicht die Nebenwirkungen
viel zu stark waren.
Das konnten sich die Hersteller
quasi selbst überlegen.
Regelt ja der Markt,
könnte man argumentieren.
So kam es, dass
unzureichend getestete Medikamente
sehr schlimme
Nebenwirkungen hervorriefen.
Da sind wirklich
furchtbare Sachen vorgefallen.
"Rund 5000 Kinder kommen
mit Missbildungen zur Welt".
Das Schlafmittel Contergan steht
im Verdacht, die Ursache zu sein.
Deswegen musste sich etwas ändern.
In den 70ern wurde eine
Arzneimittel-Reform verabschiedet.
Jetzt mussten die Hersteller
ihre Medikamente
auf Sicherheit testen
und diese Tests vorlegen.
Und es gab noch eine
revolutionäre Neuerung:
Medikamente durften
jetzt nur auf den Markt,
wenn sie auch wirkten.
Krass, oder?
Etwa so was scheinbar
Selbstverständliches,
dass ein Medikament
auch wirken muss,
ist erst
seit ein paar Jahrzehnten geregelt.
Und manchen es vielleicht
nicht ganz klar,
wie wichtig die Wirksamkeit ist.
Man könnte ja sagen, so lange das
Ding keine Nebenwirkungen hat,
schadet es ja auch niemanden.
* Schreit *
Wenn ich jetzt,
statt eines wirksamen Medikaments,
ein unwirksames Medikament kaufe.
Dann habe ich im harmloseren Fall
einfach nur Geld rausgeschmissen.
Aber vermutlich
werde ich auch noch
unnötig lange
unter meiner Krankheit leiden.
Z.B. eine schmerzende
Mittelohrentzündung.
Und ein unwirksames Medikament
ist auch nicht dazu in der Lage,
eventuelle
Komplikationen zu verhindern,
wie zum Beispiel
eine Entzündung des Innenohrs,
die dann auch
bleibende Schäden hinterlässt.
Wenn ich eine wirklich
ernsthafte Krankheit habe,
und dann meine Zeit mit irgendwelchen
und wirksamen Quatsch verschwende,
statt eine echte Therapie anzufangen,
dann kann das im Zweifel
mein Leben kosten.
Wie z.B. bei dieser 18-Jährigen:
Sie bekam einen
bösartigen Knochenkrebs.
Behandelt wurde sie
mit Geistheilung und Homöopathie.
Keine wirksamen Medikamente,
noch nicht einmal Schmerzmittel.
Und dieser Krebs
ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Drei Jahre später starb sie.
Abgemagert und mit Metastasen
in Leber und Lunge.
Eine konventionelle Behandlung
kann diese Krebsart
mit einer über 70%
Wahrscheinlichkeit heilen.
Und hätte dieser jungen Frau
zu allermindest
schlimme Qualen erspart.
Also, unwirksame Mittel
als "Medikamente" zu verkaufen
kann verdammt gefährlich sein.
Und diese Gefahr
sahen auch die Politiker damals:
Die rein formelle Registrierung
sollte ersetzt werden
durch die Zulassung.
Für eine Zulassung
ist folgendes gefordert:
Und zwar wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen, versteht sich.
So, super Reform, oder?
Das fand nicht jeder.
Mit "besonderen Therapierichtungen"
sind hier drei Alternativ-
medizinrichtungen gemeint:
Die drei sind, wohl gemerkt,
sehr verschieden.
Die Pflanzenheilkunde
ist vom Grundgedanken
eigentlich genau so,
wie die Pharmakologie.
Also in Pflanzen sind Substanzen
enthalten, die eine Wirkung haben.
In der Homöopathie kommen keine
klassischen Wirkstoffe zum Einsatz,
sondern Substanzen, die nicht
gegen diese Symptome wirken,
sondern, die ähnliche Symptome
wie die Krankheit auslösen.
Gleiches mit Gleichem bekämpfen,
oder Ähnliches mit Ähnlichem,
ist das Prinzip.
Hinzu kommt dann noch diese
seltsame Sache, dass Homöopathen,
die Substanzen so oft verdünnen,
dass in den meisten Fällen am Ende
gar nichts mehr übrig bleibt,
das wirken kann.
Schaut euch bei Gelegenheit
einfach mal dieses Video an,
das ich bei Terra X
schon mal vorgemacht habe.
Wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt zu Wirkung
oder Nichtwirkung von Homöopathie.
Die anthroposophische Medizin
verfolgt noch einmal
einen ganz anderen Ansatz.
Aber der springt jetzt den Rahmen.
Jedenfalls: diese drei
"besonderen" Therapierichtungen
hatten damals
eine einflussreiche Lobby.
Und die tat alles dafür,
um sich gegen diesen
Wirksamkeitsnachweis zu drücken.
Die Begründungen waren damals
die selben, wie heute.
Zwei der wichtigsten Argumente:
1.
Ein klassisches,
homöopathisches Präparat,
wie z.B. diese Globoli.
Soll nicht einfach
gegen Schnupfen helfen,
sondern es ist viel
individueller als das.
Wenn zum Beispiel eine verstopfte
Nase mit Schläfrigkeit am Nachmittag,
prickeln im Rücken
und dem Träumen
von früheren Ereignissen
zusammen kommt,
dann passt Aconitum napellus.
Wenn aber die verstopfte Nase
mit Schläfrigkeit am Morgen
Jucken im Auge und Träumen
von Gewittern zusammenkommt,
braucht man ein anderes Präparat:
Euphrasia officinalis.
Und genau deswegen
sagen die Homöopathen,
das ist alles so individuell,
das kann man überhaupt nicht in einer
wissenschaftlichen Studie nachweisen.
Das ist nicht sehr überzeugend.
Wenn jetzt ein Präparat helfen soll
gegen Schnupfen plus X, Y, Z,
dann muss man das halt Test
mit einer Gruppe von Patienten,
die Schnupfen haben plus X, Y, Z.
Genau das macht man nämlich auch bei
der personalisierte Medizin,
z.B. bei der modernen,
personalisieren Krebstherapie.
Mal abgesehen davon,
es gibt ja neben den Globoli auch
"homöopathische Komplex-Präparate".
Das sind die Sachen, die so aussehen,
wie normale Medizin.
Und diese Komplexpräparate
haben angeblich ganz
unindividuelle Wirkungen,
wie gegen Schnupfen oder Erkältung,
also allgemein.
Das zweite beliebte Argument,
mit dem sich
die besonderen
Therapierichtungen dafür drücken,
ihre Wirkungen
auch nachweisen zu müssen, ist:
Der Staat darf mir
nicht vorschreiben,
wie ich meine Krankheit behandle.
Darüber kann man streiten,
aber das Argument
geht am Thema vorbei.
Denn Homöopathika
sollten nicht verboten werden.
Es war angedacht,
homöopathische Mittel unter
das Lebensmittelrecht zu packen.
D.h., dass die so verkauft werden
dürfen wie Nahrungsergänzungsmittel.
Ob das die beste Lösung ist,
darüber kann man sich streiten.
Aber die Homöopathie-Anhänger
hätten sich auf jeden Fall
weiter versorgen können.
Die Entscheidungsfreiheit der Bürger
war sicherlich nicht gefährdet.
Und trotzdem hatte die
Alternativmedizin-Lobby Erfolg.
Denn sie erkämpfte sich ein paar
sehr wichtige gesetzliche Ausnahmen
bei der Arzneimittel-Reform,
die noch heute gelten.
Diese Globuli z.B.
müssen lediglich registriert werden.
Und das,
obwohl mit der Arzneimittel-Reform
die Registrierung
abgeschafft werden sollte.
Dafür wird vom Amt geprüft, ob das
Mittel nach der traditionellen
homöopathischen Lehre
hergestellt wurde.
2, 3, 4...
Und dass das Mittel nicht giftig ist.
Immerhin das.
Gut, das ist jetzt bei
diesen Globuli schnell abgehakt,
da ist außer Zucker nicht viel drin.
Bzw. nur Mengen, die so gering sind,
dass sie völlig harmlos sind.
Es gibt allerdings Homöopathika,
die nur schwach verdünnt sind.
Wo durchaus noch
giftige Substanzen drin sein können.
Die sind dann insofern
nicht traditionell,
als dass sie nicht
so stark runter verdünnt sind,
aber die werden trotzdem
als Homöopathika verkauft.
Also Homöopathie
heißt nicht automatisch ungiftig.
Bei registrierten Präparaten
steht drauf:
"registriertes
homöopathisches Arzneimittel,
daher ohne Angabe
einer therapeutischen Indikation."
Die dürfen nicht sagen,
wofür oder wogegen das gut sein soll.
Aber es gibt doch
homöopathische Mittel, wo draufsteht,
wogegen das wirkt.
Meditonsin z.B., eines der
beliebtesten homöopathischen Mittel.
Hier kommen wir zu Extrawurst 2.
Jetzt kommt der Knaller.
Meditonsin z.B. ist ein
zugelassenes homöopathisches Mittel.
Und Zulassung bedeutet, dass man
die Wirksamkeit nachgewiesen hat.
Aber jetzt haltet euch fest, wie.
Im Gegensatz zu Medikamenten,
deren Wirksamkeits-Nachweis
sich auf wissenschaftliche Studien
stützen muss,
gelten für homöopathische Mittel
ganz andere Standards.
Es werden Punkte vergeben für
verschiedenes Erkenntnismaterial.
Hier ist eine Tabelle, die zeigt,
wie viele Erkenntnispunkte
für eine Zulassung von
homöopathischen Mitteln nötig ist.
Als Wirksamkeits-Nachweis
für die Besserung der Symptome
einer leichten Krankheit
reichen zwei Punkte.
Zur unterstützenden Behandlung
einer schweren Krankheit
reichen vier Punkte.
Schauen wir,
wofür die Punkte vergeben werden.
Einen Punkt gibt es z.B. dafür,
dass die zuständige
Expertenkommission bestätigt,
dass die Wirkung
der homöopathischen Lehre entspricht.
Oder dafür,
dass andere Homöopathie-Experten
zu diesem Schluss gekommen sind.
Gleich zwei Punkte gibt es für eine
homöopathische Arzneimittelprüfung.
Klingt zwar wissenschaftlich,
ist es aber nicht.
Eine homöopathische Arzneimittel-
prüfung läuft wie folgt ab:
Laut der homöopathischen Lehre
lösen homöopathische Mittel bei
gesunden Menschen Symptome aus,
die den Symptomen
einer Krankheit ähneln.
Um herauszufinden, welche das sind,
werden Globuli
an Gesunde verabreicht.
Und die schreiben dann
wochenlang haarklein auf,
was sie so alles
an sich feststellen.
Juckende rechte Augenbraue.
All das gilt als offizielle Symptome,
gegen die dann
dieses Arzneimittel hilft.
Und das führt dazu, dass z.B.
Aconitum bei verstopfter Nase,
Schläfrigkeit am Nachmittag,
Kribbeln im Rücken und Träumen
von früheren Ereignissen wirkt.
Falls ihr euch gefragt habt,
wie man auf so etwas kommt.
Abgesehen von
diesen fragwürdigen Methoden
ist noch nicht mal eine Verblindung
oder Kontrolle
für Placebo-Effekte erforderlich.
Zwei Punkte gibt es für
diese völlig unwissenschaftliche
Arzneimittel-Prüfung
bei der Zulassung.
So geht es hier weiter:
Keiner dieser Punkte
hier in der Tabelle
reicht für einen wissenschaftlichen
Nachweis von Wirksamkeit.
Aber alleine so kann man bereits
acht Erkenntnispunkte sammeln.
Über acht Punkte benötigt
ein Hersteller erst,
wenn er ein Mittel
zur direkten Behandlung
von schweren oder lebensbedrohlichen
Krankheiten verkaufen will.
Erst dann fordert die Kommission
einen Wirksamkeits-Nachweis
im eigentlichen Sinne,
im wissenschaftlichen Sinne.
Es wird euch nicht wundern,
zu erfahren,
dass bisher kein einziges
homöopathisches Präparat
in Deutschland
so einen Nachweis geschafft hat.
Da fragt man sich doch, wer
dieses bescheuerte Punktesystem
überhaupt festgelegt hat.
Es war die zuständige
Expertenkommission
für die homöopathische
Therapierichtung höchstselbst.
Und die Experten für Homöopathie
sind natürlich Homöopathen.
Anders gesagt,
alles bis zu acht Erkenntnispunkten
sagt nichts weiter aus als:
Ja, wir Homöopathen glauben daran.
Jetzt kommt der wichtige Begriff,
der schon am Anfang fiel:
Homöopathische Präparate
brauchen keine aussagekräftigen,
wissenschaftlichen Studien,
sondern es reicht,
dass sich Homöopathen einig sind,
dass es wirkt.
Diese Regelung
nennt sich Binnenkonsens.
Also: innerer Konsens.
Innerhalb der homöopathischen
Community herrscht Einigkeit.
Das ist jetzt für Laien tricky.
Denn beim Klimawandel
spricht man auch ständig von Konsens
und dass sich
die Wissenschaftler einig sind.
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Was viele nicht wissen
oder missverstehen, ist:
Beim wissenschaftlichen Konsens
geht es keinesfalls
um eine demokratische Abstimmung
zwischen Wissenschaftslern
oder eine Übereinstimmung
von Meinungen.
Sondern es geht
beim wissenschaftlichen Konsens
einzig und allein
um die Übereinstimmung
der wissenschaftlichen Daten.
Wissenschaftliche Daten
gibt es bei der Zulassung
nach Binnenkonsens nicht.
Damit kommen wir
zum eigentlichen Witz:
Vor dem Gesetz,
vor dem deutschen Gesetz
ist mit dem Binnenkonsens
die Wirksamkeit nachgewiesen,
also nicht wissenschaftlich,
aber rein rechtlich.
Das geht so weit, dass die Firma
Klosterfrau einmal vor Gericht war,
weil sie wollte,
dass ein Produkt von ihnen
nicht als pharmakologisches
Arzneimittel eingestuft wird.
Weil es auch überhaupt nicht
pharmakologisch wirksam war.
Aber es enthielt halt
eine homöopathische Substanz,
die entsprechend verdünnt war.
Deswegen kam sie nicht damit durch.
Da wird man verrückt.
Zurück zu dem Fall mit der Abmahnung.
Bei homöopathischen Mitteln
fehlt bei allen Mitteln,
die homöopathisch daherkommen,
ein Wirksamkeits-Nachweis.
Obwohl er damit völlig recht hat,
argumentiert
die abmahnende Homöopathie-Firma so:
Noch mal: Wissenschaftlich
wurde hier gar nichts nachgewiesen,
aber ein "Wirksamkeits-Nachweis"
besteht vor dem Gesetz.
Dank Binnenkonsens.
Wir müssen uns einig sein,
ob ein Medikament wirkt oder nicht.
Das darf nicht durch ein Amt
beschlossen werden,
sondern dafür müssen
saubere wissenschaftliche Tests
durchgeführt werden.
Vor allem aber darf es nicht sein,
dass jemand akkurat über den Stand
der Wissenschaft berichtet
und dafür abgemahnt wird.
Vor allem hat ja nicht jeder die Zeit
und das Geld für einen Rechtsstreit.
Wir sind ja nicht
alle Jan Böhmermann.
Also,
liebes Bundesgesundheitsministerium,
es gibt da ein Gesetz,
das ihr dringend überarbeiten müsst.
So, Freunde der Sonne,
wir machen jetzt Folgendes:
Wir gehen jetzt alle in uns.
Wir horchen mal in uns hinein
und schreiben alle Symptome auf,
es gehört alles dazu,
die gerade vorgehen.
Grummelnder Bauch.
Oder: Wie habt ihr geschlafen?
Was habt ihr geträumt?
Dann erstellen wir mal gemeinsam
ein
Freunde-der-Sonne-Arzneimittelbild.
Also 1.:
unerklärliche Frustrationsgefühle,
Hunger...